thank you Thank You mr. president dear
colleagues let me start by expressing my
thanks for your contribution to this
very timely debate as I said during my
introductory remarks I will raise the
issue next Tuesday in the EU Western
Balkans Home Affairs in stereo that will
take place in Skopje madam general
Zapata what a Sensibility those Ankita
don't wanna Silla Commission with an
assured the Commission and the European
Parliament share the same concerns about
the migration situation in Bosnia and
Herzegovina in particular around the
town of beheads we expect that Bosnia
and Herzegovina will take urgent
measures to avoid further deterioration
of the migration and humanitarian
situation thank you for joining our
efforts in calling for the immediate
closure of the unsuitable location in
good health and the provision of
adequate accommodation across the
country for refugees and migrants this
is required to prevent a major
humanitarian crisis in the coming winter
we expect state level entity Cantona and
local authorities to cooperate and
coordinate their actions and to make the
best use of the technical and financial
assistance that the European Union has
been providing we expect law enforcement
agencies at all levels to support the
humanitarian response and to cease
counterproductive actions that endanger
the life and health over a huge Asian
miles
there should be no physical violence
violence against migrants and refugees
border guards and police should carry
out their duties in full respect of
fundamental rights we will continue
engaging with Bosnia and Herzegovina in
order to support the authorities to
prevent as I stressed before
humanitarian crisis from unfolding in
the country in the coming winter thank
you thank you very much commissioner and
the last speaker on this topic is
Minister to put on for the council
honorable members of the Parliament let
me thank you for the discussion we have
today we are fully aware of the complex
and difficult situation regarding
migrants in Bosnia and Herzegovina
and we are committed to working hard
with all the stakeholders involved to
find a solution to the current crisis
throughout the whole process we must not
forget the human aspect of the current
situation just yesterday we discussed in
this very hemicycle the protection of
the rights of the children it is
important to find a solution quickly and
to act with resolve in order to protect
people we are all aware that great
challenges lie ahead of us but we are
counting on your support in finding a
workable answer to current problems as
the finished presidency we are fully
committed within the next mff context to
allocate a sufficient amount of fund for
the migration management and to respond
both internal and external aspects of
migration nevertheless the financial aid
from the EU is just
- it is crucial indeed that the national
and local authorities do their part of
work efficiently without any day delay
that should provide refugees and
migrants help and assistance needed a
proper accommodation is a minimum
without any doubt it is utmost important
that every member state all of us follow
the rule of law and full respect of
fundamental rights at the border between
two EU countries between two countries
must be ensured MEP with an strict ask
us the Finnish presidency what we do we
as presidency we underline the
importance of full compliance with the
international law also in practice also
in our external borders the EU must
continue to actively and closely monitor
the situation on the ground and take
seriously all allegations of
mistreatment of migrants we must take
this occasion as a reminder that the
ongoing work on the reform of the common
European Asylum systems need to continue
situations like this one should not
allow a should not be allowed to repeat
thank you very much again for this next
poem to talk about pneumonia clearing
the status under comes